fires have always been part of the
lifecycle of America's forests and
letting some fires burn or even
intentionally setting them has often
been considered good forest management
but that policy has become problematic
as more and more people build homes in
forested areas
now some innovators have come up with a
new way to clear and renew our woodlands
and it's a plan that pays for itself
Barry Peterson has the story this
massive tree eating machine has a funny
name the feller buncher but a serious
job doing what nature once did thinning
out trees on the print era blanker ranch
the goal is creating a sustainable
forest so we moved here in 1969 when you
have a sustainable forest what does that
mean in terms of fires so it means we're
more fire resilient forest fires are
nature's game plan for managing a forest
a forest fire isn't always bad as long
as it's a cool burning fire you know we
do some prescribed burning and we'll do
more prescribed burning in the future as
understory that's so small yes but when
we get these big devastating crown fires
that we've seen from California all the
way through the West and into Colorado
those are extremely devastating and and
we're trying to prevent from those big
catastrophic fires the fires are bigger
for several reasons
there are heroic efforts to put them out
before they destroy the growing number
of houses built in forested areas but
that undercuts Nature's Way of burning
off undergrowth and that is making
forests dangerously dense Jonas
Feinstein is Colorado's state
conservation forester he along with
biologist ty Woodward brought us to
Colorado's Kiowa Creek Ranch owned by
the Audubon Society this area has been
cleared to look like it was for
centuries trees widely spaced we're the
worst threat is a grass fire and for
that the ponderosa pines have a nature
made defense what's great about these
trees in particular ponderosa pine is
their fire adapted they develop a thick
bark at their base that is fire
resistant so the little fires
grass fires they've got a bark that is
insulated to that absolutely but
Woodward sees danger in the dense forest
nearby when you see that do you say to
yourself I got to get rid of that stuff
or it's gonna come and get me one day oh
yeah absolutely and then you have no
forest left and you just have a dead
zone of black trees at ranchera Blanco
Ranch sitting creates its own problem
what to do with all the excess trees
including thousands of acres killed by
mountain pine beetles the infrastructure
isn't there and to invest in the
infrastructure and put the
infrastructure in to do it is quite
expensive by infrastructure you really
mean the lumber mill this almost all of
all the stuff that you're cutting yes
the sawmill so Blancas forestry products
was born a sprawling lumber mill that
produces about 20 million board feet of
lumber a year sold across two dozen
states and what helps manage the forest
comes with about 70 jobs and that helps
people up and down this rural valley
John Medina is a night watchman it's a
great boost for the economy helps
everybody helps people working here
helps of small businesses you know
there's a lot of money that's staying
here and people stayed here jose
Ontiveros
stacks wood for the kiln a job that
makes possible an enviable Colorado
lifestyle I love fishing yeah and what
electro fish sometimes to eat and just
to be out in nature and just enjoying
the elements I'll even go fishing when
it's raining and it's just just great
and it's a family affair the mill also
employs his sister stepdaughter and wife
Antoinette who works in the front office
so the logical question if it works here
why not everywhere the answer money it's
not so much a money-making Enterprise
we're trying to break even like I said
the ownership is dedicated to make this
happen so you know it is an investment
so this is really an emotional
investment it's not really a capitalist
investment absolutely it's an emotional
investment the investor is billionaire
financier
environmental philanthropist lewis bacon
trench era is one of several areas he is
working to preserve preserve things like
this a once
overground aspen grove that was cut down
and is now regrowing it's gonna be
denser than what you see in the parts
that we don't harvest but that density
will start to reduce there will be some
that die out the animals will have some
effect on some of them so it will it
will thin itself as we go on a
remarkably simple prescription for how
humans can save a forest do it Nature's
Way for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen at the trench era blanker Ranch
Colorado truly is a public service what
they're doing there it's very
complicated managing for us so somebody
can figure it out I mean there's a lot
of different ideas whether it's private
industry or the federal government if
somebody can figure out some sort of
sustainable plan long term for everyone
it would certainly be helpful
I love the learning from nature though
do it Nature's Way listen to nature